many tanzanians watched this moment with
mixed feelings
their president samir sulu hassan
getting her coveted 19 johnson
johnson injection a clear departure from
the policies implemented
by her predecessor john magufuli who
died in march
from heart problems he was one of the
handful of world leaders
who downplayed the threat of the
pandemic enchant world health
organization calls for masks
and social distancing he also rejected
vaccines
insisting the disease could be dealt
with by prayer and local remedies
when president hassan was sworn in she
said things would change
i am a mother of four children a
grandmother a wife
and president and commander-in-chief of
tanzania
i would not take the vaccine and
sacrifice my life if it was harmful
when i have all these responsibilities
and people who depend on me
the country is in its third wave of the
disease officially it has so far
recorded only 29 deaths
and 858 cases this is the beginning of a
national vaccination campaign
health workers the elderly and those
with underlying conditions are on the
priority list tanzania has received more
than a million johnson and johnson doses
donated by the u.s through the world
health organization's coverts initiative
we are not late because even other
developed nations like europe usa
are still vaccinating so i think we are
okay
the vaccine is here it's voluntary there
are those who will decide to take it
and those who will not like everyone
else it's a personal decision
now in africa only eritrea and burundi
are not vaccinating
but fewer than two percent of the
african population
has been jobbed and it's highly unlikely
the continent
will meet a whole target of vaccinating
10 percent
by september this is partly because of a
shortage of vaccines
blamed on western nations holding
millions of doses
and anti-vaccine sentiments often fueled
by conspiracy theories
and mistrusts i i'm not ready yet on my
side
because i don't know there is all the
side effects of the vaccine
and there have been too many rumors
about it so i think
i'd rather look at others and
see what happens to them and that's when
i'll be ready or i'll be willing to have
the mexicans
tanzania is well behind many countries
in vaccination rates
but the government says it has set aside
470 million dollars
to secure more doses and hopes to
inoculate 60 percent of its population
as soon as possible catherine soy al
jazeera